- [Instructor] So we are
posed with the question,
All else equal, which of the
following would likely cause
aggregate production to go up?
Pause this video,
and see which of these
you think would do that.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
This first one says,
More people enter the labor force
while the unemployment
rate stays constant.
Well, labor is an important
factor of production.
And if more people enter the labor force,
and the unemployment rate stays the same,
that means that the absolute number
of people who are working goes up.
And if everything else stays constant,
the level of technology, the capital,
the productivity per person,
well, then you would expect
to be able to produce more.
So aggregate production
should go up in this scenario.
So I'll put a check right over there.
The second one,
Velocity of money goes up.
This one is tempting,
because you might associate
a high velocity of money,
there's a lot of transactions going on,
you might associate that
with a very positive economy,
but remember, we're saying all else equal.
There might be a scenario where,
people are transacting more, there's more,
the money is circulating faster,
but the total amount of
output hasn't changed at all.
There's the same number of people
producing the same amount of goods,
using the same technology
and the same capital.
And so this does not have a direct linkage
to the output going up, all else equal.
So I'll rule this out.
Inflation goes up.
Well this, again, is tempting,
because many times, when we
are producing at a high rate,
when the economy is strong,
that's associated with higher inflation.
But there's many cases in history
where you might even have hyper-inflation
when the economy is
actually even shrinking.
And remember, we're saying all else equal.
So there's a situation
where the price level,
and the rate of the price
level going up, is going up,
but we're producing the same
amount of goods and services.
And so I will rule this out.
A new method of producing more goods
with the same resources is developed.
Well just imagine a very simple scenario.
If the whole economy consists
of me, and I produce pencils,
and let's say I can
produce 10 pencils a day,
but I just have a new method
of producing 20 pencils a day,
with the same resources, with just me,
and the same access to
wood, and the same tools,
well that's gonna dramatically increase
my aggregate production.
So one way to think
about it is this is our,
our level of technology has gone up,
which is an important
factor of production.
So I like that one.
Ten new farms are constructed.
Well, if the farms are constructed,
and I will assume that they are used,
well we're going to have more output.
They're gonna grow more things.
Our level of capital has gone up.
Once again, another important
factor of production.
So I like that.
Imports go up.
Well imports are us taking advantage,
or using someone else's output.
It doesn't say what it's
going to do to our output.
So I will rule that out.
And so this is quite intuitive.
We've talked about factors of production,
like labor, and capital, and technology.
And economists often tie this together,
taking these factors of production,
and showing how they lead
to our aggregate output
by using something known as
the Aggregate Production Function.
Aggregate, Aggregate
Production,
Function.
And it's a fancy set of words.
And what I'm about to write
seems like fancy math,
but as we'll hopefully see,
it's reasonably intuitive.
The Aggregate Production Function
is that our output is equal to A,
which, you could use a
measure of our technology.
It's often known as Total
Factor Productivity,
another fancy word,
times a function of,
that's why it's fancy, it's
using the function notation,
of our capital, and I know
capital does not start with K
in the English language, but
K for capital, and our labor.
And this is all very abstract.
If we wanted to make it a
little bit more tangible,
especially 'cause we just have
function notation in here,
we could say something like,
our aggregate output,
our aggregate production,
is equal to our Total Factor Productivity,
and then I'll make up a version of this.
Let's say, times the
square root of our capital,
times the square root of our labor.
But in general, and as
you see in this example,
you're going to see Aggregate
Production Functions
that look something like this.
The radicals, or the square
roots on capital and labor
might be a little bit different,
but they tell the same story,
that if you increase
your level of technology,
you're going to increase
your aggregate output.
If you increase your capital,
you're going to increase
your aggregate output.
And if you increase your labor,
you're going to increase
your aggregate output.
The reason why you might see square roots,
or fractional exponents
on capital or labor
is this idea of diminishing
marginal returns.
That first farm might really
add a lot to your output,
but maybe that millionth farm
might still add to your output,
but maybe at a less
level, at a lower level.
Same thing, that first,
those first 10 people
might add a lot of output to your labor,
but after you already
have 100 million people,
the next 10 will still add to
your output, but maybe less.
At least that's what these
mathematical models are saying.
So big picture, it's pretty intuitive
that if you hold everything else equal,
and if you increase the factors
of production, well then,
that would likely cause your
aggregate production to go up.
But economists like to
describe things mathematically,
and that's what's going on in something
like an Aggregate Production Function.
Now last but not least, a related idea
to an Aggregate Production Function
is this idea of productivity.
Pro-duc-tivity.
We already viewed A as
Total Factor Productivity,
but it's really a measure of
the technology in an economy.
Typically, when people talk
just about regular productivity,
they're talking about output
per capita, output per person.
So really, what they're doing is,
they're thinking about
aggregate production, so Y,
and then they're dividing it by labor.
So then they would divide it by labor.
So this would be output per person.
And so you could imagine,
if technology improves,
holding labor constant,
well then your output per
person is going to improve.
If your capital goes up, which
would improve your output,
holding labor constant,
then once again, your
productivity would improve.
Per person, you're able to
produce more in your economy.